yo
Tyler Devin alley hello sorry I'm uh
on I'm on a call or on a thread
I got these made
coming out soon I'm doing a little wear
and tear test and I know this do you see
that little crease
see that
that's not gonna fly
that doesn't work for me
remember how he said a lot of stuff
doesn't get made because I'm a
perfectionist
that's what I mean
Jay our new uh creative designer is
going to get it done I already know that
he's gonna Crush that
um
I just letting you guys know why things
take so long sometimes
what up
you guys are currently on top of my
alcohol bucket and uh nails
you know what I need I need I need a lot
of things to help me
maybe a laptop stand
also
Dirty Dan so
all right guys sorry for the late
podcast premiere
I'm already uploaded the podcast at 6 00
am
it just processed it's 2 30.
that's stupid
YouTube really likes to
test our patients man
truly
I smoke a fat bowl
hi
what am I smoking this is called White
ashes OG I'm down to the last little
bowl
what up how's your day Steven Pruitt
hello hello hello
we're about to hit 10K on Facebook let's
go dope as usual on Facebook guys
a little bong rip action
what other podcast gets this high I
would like to know I mean obviously we
podcast
[Music]
ah damn
that was a little harsh
[Music]
yeah I heard a little bit
all right
sometimes people get high
here we go
so what's up guys Hash House on the Pod
would be good yeah it's supposed to be
this week it's supposed to be last week
it's supposed to be the week before it's
supposed to be the week before it's
supposed to be the week before that
you gonna bug John I'm done asking
that got me
happy early fourth yo
dope is we got five minutes until the uh
episode drops that's a little harsh
though
Mario figure this is the uh Forrest Gump
Mario
doing anything to the fullest time huh
stepping in my office
a lot of different weeds going on here
this is called banana Cannon
this is
cbx Ayahuasca
the deep east
this is um
oh yeah look at this I need to smoke
this right on the stem still
from the grill all right I'm smoking all
these this week I'm tripping
it's been too long I have been smoking
these
um what it is with me dude I'm a hoarder
when it comes to weed so I'll be like yo
I want that weed looks so good I need to
film it I don't need to smoke it first I
need to film it while I smoke it because
it's too dope
and then I'll forget
that's what happens when you forget so I
need to smoke it all I'm gonna smoke it
all this week
oh
all right
um
boom
you can't see that hold on
this is called beso yeah and this is
from the deep east
[Music]
foreign
so many nugs on here I'm tripping this
is the podcast Channel my bad
this is dope is yellow stuff I'll just
take bomb ribs on here
this will be the last time we show all
this stuff
Jay bear what's up
all right
okay guys here we go
we're almost there two minutes to the
premiere drops
let's go
Animalia hello
legal weed in Ireland one day
one day you'll have that
all right here we go guys the second I
rip this I'm gonna press stop
and go straight over the podcast the
podcast is dropping right now in two
minutes
two and a half hours long
so get ready okay I don't even remember
what it was about I mean I already was
high
[Music]
right
thank you
guys thank you for being here I'm
hopping off let's hop straight over to
the podcast have a dope ass day
foreign